[Music]
you have said and you've talked about
this in the past you're a massive prints
fan and obviously the past way several
days ago and I'm just wondering you know
how is this affecting you because I know
you're assuming my life right right now
because any time the same thing happened
with Michael Jackson dies I don't know
if you guys gone down this thing but you
want it first of all how why you know
like prints is one of those people have
you told me he was gonna live forever
I'd be like yeah of course tonight
prints right but then he died and it's
just like Oh mortality is real yeah and
so and now is just me like staring at
the internet screaming things like how
long does it got down toxicology reports
it right right I had a incredible
experience with him when I was I hosted
a show in others in Las it was a Las
Vegas right Jeff it was like a benefit
and all these great performers were
there they asked me to host this thing
was a benefit and Prince is one of the
performers yeah but I didn't see him I
was just but Stevie one point Stevie
Wonder's out on stage playing and there
was this rumor that Prince was gonna
show up and play with Stevie Wonder
onstage and surprise everybody
and I'm backstage and I'm hearing it I'm
hearing it from the production people
like some crazy rumor I'm here like no
Prince gonna and I'm just watching
Stevie Wonder play and then all of a
sudden I just felt this presence next to
me and I heard hey and I look over and
it's Prince and he's backstage and he's
watching Stevie Wonder with me and
Stevie Wonder's playing this amazing I
say oh hey how you doing when we chat a
little bit yeah and then Stevie Wonder's
Band he's a great drummer Stevie
Wonder's drummers by anyway and Prince
is doing all this incredible the best
air drumming I've ever seen I mean
everyone's done some air drumming he was
doing it perfectly and intricately and
hitting everything just right you got a
new word drum he knew we were drums were
he was being amazing and I said to him
so the rumor is that you're gonna go out
there and play with Stevie Wonder he
went yeah that's not true and I was like
oh you're not gonna go out and he's like
no I'm not gonna go out they wanted me
to but I'm not gonna do it and I told
them that's not gonna happen and I said
oh okay cuz that's the rumor he said no
I know it's a rumor but it's not gonna
happen I went cool thirty seconds later
a guy comes and puts the guitar around
prints his neck he looks at me and
smiles and walks out and plays
superstition play superstitious twinkle
in his eye like yeah gotcha I'm gonna go
be Prince now but I look looked at Conan
O'Brien and said this guy can't keep a
secret yeah yeah this man cannot be
trusted
you